>>Where do I need to go to begin my
project? Tara, what is your plan?
>>Developing a calm, neutral,
assertive voice is part
of the teacher's own self-regulation,
which allows them to help students
to be self-regulated and to
be secure in the knowledge
that the teacher will be receptive
to them, but also in control.
>>All right, everyone partner up.
>>The tone of voice we
try to use when we speak
with our students is what we would
call calm, neutral and assertive.
>>Show your partner any
emotion, any emotion.
>>We found it to be immensely important
for helping kids to do the right thing
and to guide them and to redirect them.
>>Self-regulation is the way that
we manage ourselves to behave
in the ways we intend to behave rather
than becoming overwhelmed with anger
or fear or anxiety and acting out.
>>Boy: [Screams.]
>>I have a question, are you
starting a new structure?
>>If we're talking in a
voice that is too aggressive,
we might accidentally be using fear
to manipulate children's behavior.
>>And we're using that.
>>Let's let him take
off the screws first.
>>Instead of helping them to
gain that intrinsic motivation
to do the right thing
for the right reasons.
>>And sometimes it's not
safe to go to the beach.
>>Okay, one at a time.
>>Because there are shark attacks.
>>Yes, I heard be careful of the sharks.
>>So the sweet spot is calm,
neutral, assertive and the teachers
who get the best responses
from kids are the ones
that have mastered that the best.
>>All right, we're going to get
ready now for close reading.